[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale et nous sommes le lundi à 18
octobre voici les titres de cette
édition
les établissements scolaires ont rendu
hommage à samuel pâtit il y a un an le
professeur d'histoire-géographie été
victime d'une attaque terroriste à
conflans sainte honorine cérémonie ton
des changes ou encore marche blanche
était organisée ce week end la semaine
nationale ella a débuté ce lundi
l'association européenne contre les
leucodystrophies invite entreprises et
établissements scolaires a participé à
l'événement au programme dicté ou encore
l'opération mets tes baskets et après
l'élection place à l'installation du
nouveau conseil municipal à trappes à
l'irad et reprend comme en 2020
l'écharpé de maire pour marquer son
opposition après une campagne sous
tension othman nasri et son colistier
mustapha larbaoui ne se sont pas rendus
sur place
et puis frédéric vital vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche et de l'innovation s'est rendu
à châteaufort ce matin une visite de
l'entreprise safran dans le cadre du
plan d'investissements france 2030 un
plan qui vise à investir dans
l'innovation
l'objectif du déplacement échanger sur
le développement des transports aériens
durable tels que l'avion bas carbone
[Musique]
et il y a un an samuel pâtit professeur
d'histoire-géographie été victime d'une
attaque terroriste islamique près du
collège de conflans sainte honorine où
il exerçait elle dézonage ont été
rendues dans différentes villes des
yvelines samedi 16 octobre 2021 une
journée en sa mémoire lui était
consacrée le récit des commémorations
par célia gars tsongo patrick jacques de
dixmude et grégory canal et dès le
vendredi 15 octobre les établissements
scolaires ont rendu hommage à samuel
pâti comme au collège jean zay à
verneuil sur seine lors d'un cours
d'histoire géographie et d'enseignement
moral et civique une classe de 3e a
travaillé sur deux thèmes de réflexion
nous avions décidé de nous intéresser
plus particulièrement à ce que fait le
professeur d'histoire géographie
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qu'on
apprend en histoire géographie et
pourquoi en étudier l'histoire
géographie samuel
tu fais lundi à jamais de notre commune
d essai longue ici dans notre collège
danton collège annuels qu'il nous
semblait évident que deux gros matches
c'est au collège du bois donne de
conflans sainte honorine qu'une grande
cérémonie d'hommage à samuel pâtit était
organisée à huis clos samedi 16 octobre
professeurs personnels éducatifs et
élèves ont pris la parole le ministre de
l'éducation nationale était sur place
un sentiment d'avoir de solidarité avec
la famille de samuel fatigue avec ses
proches avec ses collègues avec ses
élèves à tous les professeurs de france
aussi est au fond avec tous les français
un procès les français qui le jour de sa
mort il ya un an était totalement
bouleversé par ce qui s'est passé et
quand il ya une mort aussi tragiquement
aussi absurde c'est notre unité qui lui
permet donc qui permet de lui donner un
sens à l'issue de ce premier hommage une
marche blanche est partie du collège
jusqu'à la place de la liberté un
discours a été donné par le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine ému par
l'événement le 16 octobre 2020 restera
un jour à jamais marquée d'une pierre
blanche dans l'histoire de conflans
sainte honorine je pense que le sens de
cet hommage c'est à la fin d'un âge
assez mais elle pâtit et en même temps
un moment de rassemblement
indispensable pour qu'on puisse en
ensemble échanger et discuter est resté
soudé un monument en forme des livres
ouverts a été également dévoilé symbole
de la liberté d'expression des centaines
de personnes étaient présentes
c'est vraiment cra lamentable
pour un chat mais c'est fait d'ailleurs
on pourra pas l'oublier non plus apporté
mon soutien un soutien moral surtout à
la famille à la commune
et tous les conflanais dont fait partie
un square a également été nommé samuel
pâti en face de l'université la sorbonne
à paris
[Musique]
et ce lundi 18 octobre c'était le
lancement national de la 18e édition de
la dictée d'ela l'association qui lutte
contre les maladies génétiques dit
leucodystrophies à saint germain en laye
l'événement se dérouler au collège
marcel robbie avec une centaine d'élèves
des écoles primaires de la ville à
nicolas landry était sur place regarder
attention les enfants c'est parti
un texte d'hervé le tellier intitulé la
gymnastique des mots voilà la version
2021 de la dictée d'ela au collège
marcel robbie de saint-germain-en-laye
une centaine d'élèves de primaire se
sont prêtés au jeu un exercice en
présence de benoît carloni jeune homme
de 30 ans atteint de leucodystrophie
venue avec ses parents c'est une
solidarité qui n'est pas commune
aujourd'hui c'est c'est super pour
benoît il a 30 ans bon maintenant il ya
d'autres enfants qui naissent avec cette
maladie et il faut trouver quelque chose
pour chaque nom sur la maladie comédien
et chanteur david ban s'est mué en
professeur des écoles lui qu'on peut
voir dans plus belle la vie ou la
comédie musicale 1789 les amants de la
bastille il est parrain de l'association
ela depuis 2015 j'essaie de faire en
sorte que ce soit un petit moment de
partage que les enfants s'en souviennent
aussi il ya aussi une partie des enfants
qui ont qui contribue à mettre en place
cette dictée donc je trouve que c'est
bien c'est courageux leurs pas
côté organisation des élèves de 4e du
collège marcel en mobile décoration mise
en place des feuilles accueil des
invités ils se mobilisent à leur manière
contre la maladie
personne encore n'a trouvé de 2 par
exemple de médicaments pour soigner
cette maladie donc je trouve que c'est
bien de participer à cette association
je crois que c'est assez important de
participer à cette association parce que
à de l'argent qui est récolté dans cette
association et ça aide aux personnes qui
sont handicapés à cause de cette maladie
la matinée solidaire c'est fini sur une
note de musique encore fort un extrait
du dernier album de david barnes
et je vous le disais donc un peu plus
tôt la semaine nationale est là vient de
débuter et se déroulera jusqu'au 23
octobre à l'origine de l'événement
l'association européenne contre les
leucodystrophies
un groupe de maladies génétiques
héréditaires qui s'attaque au système
nerveux et dont on ne guérit pas
aujourd'hui pour lancer l'événement
les dictées ont été organisées partout
en france pour sensibiliser au combat
contre cette maladie
aurélie lesous professeur de lettres à
vous êtes avec nous vous étiez au
collège marcel robidas saint germain les
ce matin bonsoir bonsoir il est vrai
nous sommes exactement vont soirée
françois malherbe représentants des
associations et la dont les yvelines
vous êtes également avec nous merci
beaucoup bonsoir
vous est également papa d'un petit
garçon atteint d'une leucodystrophie
je voulais voir avec vous directement
donc en premier aujourd'hui les
leucodystrophies concerne une trentaine
de maladies puisque c'est un groupe de
maladies est ce que pouvait on peut vous
expliquer ça et donc quel est l'objectif
derrière de l'association ela
l'objectif par rapport aux opérations
déjà et la dictée et la dictée est fait
pour annoncé préparer mets tes baskets
c'est dans la foule m pas selon les
établissements pour évidemment récoltés
en tout premier lieu des dons
afin de financer
sur deux axes
financer la recherche contre les
leucodystrophies puisque les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques sont assez
peu intéressés par ces maladies
orphelines
financer des équipes de recherche
et notre axe pour apporter un soutien
aux familles qui ont besoin à la fois de
besoins matériels de soutien
psychologique
donc là vous nous parliez des dons
justement donc j'imagine dans la
recherche peut-être dans la recherche de
traitements puisqu'aujourd'hui on l'a
dit il n'y a pas de traitement pour
cette maladie pour ces maladies oui
c'est le problème essentiel à
l'initiative pour
essayer d'expliquer simplement de
neurones sont entourés d'une donc si
vous l'avez dit parfaitement en lançant
le sujet
atteinte du système nerveux central
note dans notre cerveau les neurones
sont entourés d'une gaine qui s'appelle
la myéline est malheureusement cette
nuit et line qui est attaquée
se dégrade et donc on voit nos enfants
peu à peu dépérir et c'est pour ça qu'il
ya pour nous vraiment l'urgence de
trouver des traitements
donc votre fils est atteint d'une
leucodystrophie
justement comment vit la maladie au
quotidien
il est très difficile du fait justement
que ce soit une maladie dégénérative
parce que d'étapes en étapes je vois je
connais benoît je connais aussi d'un
build and on est une grande famille a eu
là et chaque année on voit quand même
des difficultés les difficultés
s'accentuer chez nos enfants donc c'est
quelque chose qui est excessivement
difficile mais on s'adapte pour
l'instant comme il n'ya pas de
traitement on se bagarre pour qu'ils
pourront trouver mais comme il n'ya pas
de traitement on en est à traiter des
symptômes qui apparaissent je vais
donner l'exemple de mon fils l'a
dernièrement sur sa dernière irm le
cerveau a montré qu'
il y avait une atteinte de la partie qui
commandait le système respiratoire donc
aujourd'hui il est objet de porter un
appareil respiratoire toutes saoulées
toutes les nuits pour pouvoir respirer
correctement voit la composent on
s'adapte mais ces voix là c'est une
c'est une épreuve quotidienne
or il y eu d'enfant ne donne beaucoup
d'énergie à vous et moi si ça
aurait les yeux on en parlait donc cezio
pardon on en parlait tout à l'heure pour
sensibiliser à la maladie dont il ya la
dictée ela qui avait lu aujourd'hui vous
y étiez elle est organisée depuis cinq
ans est-ce que vous ne pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi c'est important de se
mobiliser justement comme ça pour
l'association ela bhatt bien sûr que ça
fait de nombreuses années que je suis
enseignante et donner du sens à notre
enseignement c'est très important
expliquer aux élèves que l'engagement
c'est essentiel que on est des citoyens
que ce sont les citoyens de demain qu'on
n'est pas juste là pour pour leur
enseigner le ramener un savoir mais là
aussi pour les faire réfléchir alors moi
dans le précédent collège où j'étais
d'ailleurs auxquels je rends hommage
c'est le collège darius milhaud à
sartrouville on avait déjà entamé un
soutien fort à l'association et quand je
suis arrivé à saint germain en laye au
collège marcel robbie je me suis dit ben
voilà on va essayer de semer aussi un
saint germain la petite graine est là et
ça fait effectivement cinq ans que
j'arrive à organiser des événements avec
les aléas sanitaires ça a été compliqué
mais on a eu 6 et ce matin on était une
bonne centaine à avoir pu donner de
notre énergie et notre main pour les
enfants d'ela et le soutien qu'on peut
leur apporter ce matin était symbolique
mais on était là avec notre énergie
présent et c'est très important pour moi
de d'insuffler cette énergie a à mes
élèves que je remercie d'ailleurs
beaucoup on les a vus je suis très très
fier d'eux et voilà et je pense que pour
les familles c'est c'est important de
leur montrer qu'on est con ella et donc
justement pour votre classe c'était un
investissement qui allait au-delà
finalement de la dictée puisque c'est un
projet que vous avez préparé en cours
tout à fait avec le soutien bien sûr
j'avais tout mon jeu si adam smith m'a
donné aucune telle albert type logique
obtient c'est dans un tel projet donc
avec les élèves de 4e et que vous avez
pu voir sur le petit reportage on a tout
organisé eux qui ont lancé des
invitations qui ont invité la famille
l'oni qui ont accueilli notre parrain
qui était ce matin présent des élèves
des écoles alentours des élèves de cm2
voilà sont mes élèves qui ce matin et
elle à 8 heures tous sur le pied de
guerre pour voilà décorer notre salle
accueillir c'est aussi un moment pour
eux de prendre des responsabilités et
illustré maintenant des compétences
parfois différente de celle qu'on attend
d'eux quand ils soient en classe donc je
suis vraiment fier parce que c'était pas
facile c'est c'est une grande
responsabilité et ils ont été à la
hauteur je les félicite et je les
remercie
c'est important justement selon vu que
l'éducation nationale participent à
cette sensibilisation des jeunes mais
bien sûr bien sûr donner du sens à ce
qu'on fait on n'est pas juste des
passeurs de savoir pour moi c'est très
très important bah de les ouvrir sur le
monde de donner du sens à ce que ce que
je peux leur apprendre moi je suis
professeur de lettres classiques et bien
quand on parle citoyenneté on peut en
parler en latin effectivement et puis
bah on peut en parler voilà qu'est ce
que c'est qu'être citoyen basset s'est
aussi donné de son temps être solidaire
et parfois ça permet de mettre en
parallèle battre nos cours concrètement
voilà voilà on est dans le concret et la
solidarité l'entraidé pour moi c'était
partie des valeurs les plus importantes
je crois encore plus aujourd'hui avec
que les délais moment qu'on vient de
vivre un tous je pense que c'est
vraiment essentiel puis donner de notre
énergie c'était un très beau moment ce
matin
françois malherbe brièvement il ya aussi
un autre événement qui va se dérouler
cette semaine c'est justement mets tes
baskets et bats la maladie est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire deux trois mots
là-dessus oui donc chaque établissement
qui s'est créée il y en à 2532 enfants
pour l'opération mets tes baskets
soit fait une opération sportive
donc les jeunes cherchent des parrains
pour pour cette compétition par
compétition ce n'est pas une compétition
mais cet effort sportif
et donc qui est organisée soit la suite
de la dictée donc cette semaine pour
certains établissements mais c'est à la
libre appréciation d'établissement et de
ce qu'ils organisent
une opération sportive donc symbolique
gilles de mettre ses baskets pour des
enfants qui ne peuvent plus courir
et donc c'est également au choix des
établissements
certains
organiser des compétitions de
des tournois ton à tennis de table
basket mais là le l'opération la plus
symbolique choisie et souvent le relais
la course de relais parce que justement
le relais c'est fort on passe le témoin
on passe le bâton au suivant et donc
c'est une opération
qui est essentiel pour l'association au
niveau des dons
c'est 40 et 40 à 50% du fonctionnement
de l'association donc mets tes baskets
et vraiment très très importante pour
nous
et justement pour ce qui est pour ce qui
est des dons vous pouvez le faire bien
sûr en participant aux événements ou en
contactant directement l'association
toutes les informations sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
beaucoup aurélie cezio professeur de
lettres je le rappelle a du collège
marcel robbie à saint germain en laye et
puis à vous monsieur malherbe d'avoir
été avec nous aussi en tant que
représentant des yvelines est aussi perd
finalement d'un enfant qui atteint de
cette maladie merci à tous leurs maux
[Musique]
après sa disparition le samedi 9 octobre
les obsèques dabola san bani sadr se
sont tenues ce samedi 16 octobre au
cimetière des gones à versailles premier
président de la république islamique
d'iran il vivait à versailles depuis son
exil en 1981 en 1981 par dont sa
dernière volonté est resté enterré en
france tant que la démocratie n'était
pas instaurée en iran un reportage de
nicolas landry
c'est un personnage de l'histoire
iranienne qui s'en va le premier
président de la république islamique
d'iran abolhassan bani sadr a reçu un
dernier hommage une inhumation à
versailles autour de sa famille et plus
d'une centaine de personnes de la
communauté iranienne ça permet un peu de
si vous voulez de deux mois en ressentir
la douleur quand elle est partagée bas
surtout avec des gens que j'embrasse
alors que qui pleurent que je ne connais
même pas il a combattu toute sa vie sans
jamais rien lâcher toujours dans le sens
de la démocratie et des droits de
l'homme et pour la grandeur de l'iran
après son exil en france en 1981
abolhassan bani sadr continuer le combat
depuis versailles un domicile placé sous
protection policière hommes politiques
mais aussi grand père il s'occupait de
ses petits-enfants
merci navarre est un exemple de courage
de combativité de soi tout au long de
votre vie pour le peuple iranien
jusqu'au dernier instant tourner et
proche de l'ayatollah khomeini il a
participé à la révolution iranienne en
élu président de la république islamique
d'iran 1980 il est destitué 17 mois plus
tard et contraint à l'exil en cause ses
positions sur la démocratie et sur les
libertés individuelles j'ai passé toute
ma jeunesse
à suivre son parcours et puis c'est un
homme qui aimait bien il mais bien les
gens
et donner beaucoup d'importance à
surtout à l'indépendance la liberté et
démocratie cette cérémonie l'occasion de
respecter la dernière volonté d'alassane
bani sadr reposer en france tant que la
démocratie ne sera pas instauré en iran
et côté politique locale installation du
conseil municipal à trappes a eu lieu
vendredi 15 octobre sa liste arrivée en
tête dès le premier tour avec 58% des
suffrages c'est tout naturellement à
lire ab qui a été élu maire de la
commune de 32 mille habitants un conseil
d'installation tendue à l'image de la
campagne qui a eu lieu ces quelques
semaines qui ont suivi l'annulation de
l'élection de juin 2020 un reportage de
mélanie poquet
les soutien d'al hira des sons venus en
nombre vendredi 15 octobre pour voir la
tête de liste génération être élu maire
lors de ce conseil d'installation mois
avec trente et une voix il ya énormément
de travail à réaliser la trappe on se
bat pour l'égalité pour la dignité des
habitants de cette ville il ya eu
beaucoup d'intelligence dans cette
campagne qui a été violente qui a été
rude où je vous ai pris beaucoup de
coups personnellement mais j'ai surtout
perçu la capacité extraordinaire
d'engagement de mobilisation des
trappistes le travail le travail le
travail cette fois dans la sérénité
l'apaisement loin des polémiques lancées
par nos adversaires du côté de
l'opposition othmana through et mustapha
larbaoui de la liste union républicaine
pour trappe était absent guy malandain
s'est quant à lui absenté après avoir
refusé de présider la séance et le vote
pour élire les deals luc miserait seul
représentant de trappes à gauche a voté
blanc je serai en soutien de tout ce qui
est positif pour les trappistes et quand
j'aurai une différence a signifié je le
ferai dauman reconstructives comme on
l'a fait de 2014 à 2020 avec trappe à
gauche on est très attentif sur sur les
aspects du logement de la vie des
habitants
il ya des réponses extrêmement
importantes apportées à ce niveau là on
est très vigilant sur l'éducatif c'est à
dire que nous on pense qu'il faut
beaucoup plus de qualité une soirée
tendue à l'image de la campagne le
conseil d'installation a aussi élu aux
adjoints au maire
[Applaudissements]
la commune de graisser verra bientôt
s'implanter un élevage de quarante mille
poules pondeuses sur son territoire la
demande avait été enregistrée par un
arrêté en juillet 2019 ce dernier avait
été contesté par des riverains le
tribunal administratif de versailles a
rejeté et les deux requêtes déposées
contre ce projet celui ci a donc été
validé par un jugement ce vendredi 15
octobre le site choisi pour
l'implantation de l'élevage ne
présentait pas de sensibiliser
sensibilité environnementale
particulière selon le tribunal et se
trouverait suffisamment éloignés des
zones protégées environnantes et c'est
la fin de ce journal merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis dans un instant
retrouver michael elle me d'euros à la
présentation de votre magazine sportif
accompagné de bixente mais rien sont
esteban pour les résultats du week end
très bonne soit sur tv 78
[Musique]